[Musik]
jedem a hetz gefühl auch aravane rezai
mit dem sofa nötig stress
[Musik]
weit schlimmer als fahrer hat der zu
hause frauen tg ältere liebt den
fussball wir gewinnen also zielgruppe
nicht ganz anders war
[Musik]
das ist tagtäglich passiert hat er
gewusst aber josef wattenweiler hat
niemals damit gerechnet dass es ihn
treffen könnte
er ist auf dem nachhauseweg als
plötzlich zwei junge männer vor ihm
stehen und zu schlagen zwar verbinden
bafa de arbeitsmittel hinter dem bahnhof
in winterthur ist es passiert die
jugendlichen verfolgen ihn halten ihn
auf er wird niedergeschlagen und
ausgeraubt und zu wenig oder die täter
erbeuten 43 fragten
diese videoaufnahmen werden den
haupttäter später überführen video
kameras filmen auch josef wattenweiler
nach dem überfall
er sucht hilfe bei einem nahegelegenen
polizeiposten doch um diese zeit ist der
posten nicht mehr besetzt
[Musik]
josef wattenweiler steht unter schock
und will wieder gehen
da kommt hilfe
erst jetzt realisiert er wie schwer er
verletzt ist tiefe messerstiche im
brustbereich unweit von herz und lunge
[Musik]
november sichert london dort zum darm
und marzahn nach der tat colt der
haupttäter in einer nachricht an
kollegen er habe gerade eben einem
niedergestochen
er ist der täter er hat josef warten
weiter über fand david heute 22 jahre
alt seit bald zwei jahren in der
strafanstalt saxerriet wir haben ihn
damals an der gerichtsverhandlung
getroffen david ist bereit mit uns über
seine tat zu sprechen
zur tatzeit ist er 19 jahre alt er
trinkt nimmt drogen und holt sich
notfalls mit gewalt das was er will
[Musik]
erwartet ich sagen kann du strauß
gewähltes schrag sie und er selbst
gestern einen tag habe ich viel konzert
und dann bin ich der regierung darauf
hoffe ich war schon in anderen kantonen
herrscht endlich denkt warum ich
geschlafen und das geld wie wird
eigentlich tatra in der slowakei für die
enten das weiß zu bedrohen neutralen
stuttgart ist eigentlich ein plan ich
sehe das ja dann stolpert und
unabsichtliche posting tor aber sie in
dem vorwort nachrichtenseite halten
eingestochen
ja ja erst die wenn ich aufstehe und
danach dann aber den deutschen leitindex
dann weglaufen klingen schnitt rechnet
sie hier bricht was der stunde und herr
staatsanwalt einer farbe dass er
wirklich
spieltag mit 30 punkten im blick zu sein
scheine sogar das lohngefüge schon
klappen herzen und finde ich selber das
rechtfertige david ist ein schweizer
auch seine eltern stammen von hier
da er zur tatzeit folgerichtig ist trägt
er die volle verantwortung voll gerecht
begegnet er dem opfer das erste mal seit
dem überfall hersteller direkt crotta
weist zwar stetig wenn das wirklich so
ich fahre ihnen das final four haben
viele gedanken darüber gemacht wie ich
das sehe ich aber was wird enorme selber
kreiert und genau gelesen nicht wenn du
noch mal ganz anders
das urteil fünf jahre und drei monate
gefängnis
wie ist das einen menschen zu schlagen
und zu verletzen
was ist das für ein gefühl werder gewann
skispringer überhaupt ungefähr so viel
adrenalin kick unrechts berufs thema zu
dem moment nur dass der im moment
überhaupt noch nie lebten wir in der
schweiz so sicher wie heute
und doch die gewalt auf der straße nimmt
zu es ist samstagabend johann wild habe
und oskar stücke von der basler
jugendpolizei haben nachtschicht
schweizweit verzeichnet basel die
höchste dichte an gewaltstraftaten
das urbane basel das zentrum im
dreiländereck schweiz frankreich
deutschland zieht viele amerikaner der
promenade wenn es warm essen und
begangen noch ist es ruhig und der abend
aber es ist wochenende da häufen sich
die schlägereien messerstechereien und
überfälle
das team der jugendpolizei die beiden
sind zivil unterwegs
ihr ziel präsenz markieren kontakte
knüpfen beziehungen herstellen und so
gewalt verhindern
[Musik]
allein
am theater mitten in basel
auf dem platz treffen sich junge
erwachsene und jugendliche
die stimmung ist nur friedlich kommen
alkohol und drogen ins spiel und kann
sie jederzeit geben
der kippe flex genutzte alles
weil sowieso geld lustig passiert alles
möglich
[Musik]
drei bis viermal in der nacht kommen die
beiden hier vorbei je öfter sie vor ort
sind desto eher lässt sich die gewalt
verhindern
[Musik]
wirklich verlässliche beziehungen zu
erwachsenen das weiß man heute
vermindern
die gewaltbereitschaft und beziehung
bedeutet auch grenzen und regeln zu
akzeptieren
so wie sie selbst vor kurzem verboten
also wenn sie keiner station zeigen
kommuniziert haben
[Musik]
wie kommt so
pauli aufgeschlossen haben
anhand der show polit letzte polizist
problem ist überall sind glasflaschen
jetzt die fälle die alkoholflaschen
darüber allmählich der weiß man wie viel
alkohol tier liegt deutsche konsumiert
hat und da jetzt dort wo sie zum teil
schon lange wie sie sich präsentieren
und zeigen wir sind die größte gruppe
bisher müssen stach es so schnell
passiert das stimmige beim antrieb tosca
stucki und ihren wildhaber werden zu
einem einsatz der kantonspolizei gerufen
rivalisierende jugendgruppen sollen hier
aufeinander losgegangen sein kollege
frei
es geht um macht und ehre und um frauen
vor allem für jugendliche ist das
offenbar oft auslöser für schlägereien
auf dem theaterplatz sind junge
jugendliche und junge erwachsene
menschen mit migrationshintergrund und
deutsches problem
das ist um eine frau gegangen ist kommt
meine jungs mal was ist bekannt durch
eine andere gruppe der ochse maschinen
kollegin oder freundin vermeinte gemacht
hat ein technisches zu verbalen
auseinandersetzung uterus sage für die
requisiten de oder requirieren war
glitter hat die schienen zu gemangelt
also sein kollege dass man jetzt alle
wieder frieden nach sehen wir die sache
unter jungen erwachsenen wie migration
und schwierig ideale situation ist so
sehr
aber ob das mal gemeine solches nicht
normal gemeint es geht also jugendliche
schweizer wo aggressiv können sie wäre
situation sind halt jetzt jugendliche
und junge erwachsene mit
migrationshintergrund die gewalt auf der
straße ist ein gesellschaftliches
phänomen und betrifft schweizer und
ausländer gleichermaßen
[Musik]
warum schlägt ein junger mensch zu geht
es um macht um stärke vor ihm hatten die
anderen früher angst
heute ist er ein rapper und übt für sein
nächstes konzert die musik die texte
zieht aggressiv aber genau damit kriegt
er seine wut heute in den griff
[Musik]
irgendwie ist mir das manchmal aber sie
ist also in einer riesen war muss man
sexy wird denn wir verstehen uns selber
letztendlich so zurückblicke irgendwas
leser denkt der letzten 16 gesetzten
teilweise alles total
dieses bündel akten dokumentiert einen
kleinen teil seiner bewegten
vergangenheit einen ort als
sachbeschädigung fahren ohne führer ist
widerhandlung gegen das waffengesetz 15
gehalten beim ein unfall in der handlung
immer das bedeuten dass mit dem gesetz
ja das mache ich das
[Musik]
wir fahren mit einem dahin zurück wo er
aufgewachsen ist
mit 14 hat er das erste mal zugeschlagen
ein falscher blick reichte damals
manchmal schon aber dort mal vielleicht
nur das kann halt nur dass also die
hacken staat und gesellschaft dem
abschluss khk das einzige was ich bin
stolz und dankbar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tennis ist einer seiner jugendfreunde
heute machen die beiden zusammen musik
aufgewachsen ist er im im st galler
rheintal in altstätten seine mutter eine
schweizerin ist alleinerziehend den
vater kennt er nicht von ihm hat er
einzig seinen albanischen vornamen und
dennis beide haben zu hause gewalt
erlebt dennis vom vater bei einem war es
später der stiefvater und ja ja kein
problem mit ihrem hof durch kein problem
in mehreren so gibt viel zu moral städte
lauft also diesmal dank titel auf der
tour und sie lügen über schräge also
weiß dass die leute angst also so weiß
niemand welche mit gastronomie die ak
bist du angst und hat daraus gelernt und
ich spüre die blick und so sieht ist es
aber gar keine macht also dort wo
landwirte sehen und schauen dem ist der
ältere
er war zwei klassen über den ich
zwei lehrern zu burnout rewe 2 der
dritte geburtstag feiert wird dani clos
selber ja auch schon auf also ein
herzlicher aggression ist damit die zeit
wo man wo man dann begegnet nach es aber
nicht wahrhaben will es ist dem vater
thomas speck zeigen du musst und ist
jetzt mehr schlechter kreuzt der
schulhausplatz im sankt gallischen
altstetten ein beliebter treffpunkt für
die jungen
das war auch bei ihm und denise herrmann
und bringt nix ein problem angegangen
oder er im reinbeker aber der reinen mit
einer stadt schlage aber also bringt es
nicht überwachte daniel schock sagt
willi schütz zu mir selber aber das buch
zeichnet mit der nitro fest ich will
keine umbringen oder will selber und
will der einen seite man den star über
die mutter wird sich darüber freuen dass
du eine kaputt schlagen will sie
beleidigt worden
das liegt ja als spaß so ziemlich mit
mehr verwendet da war schon oft gegen
und kolleg aber wenn damit sein fach nur
dann erholen wenn es einfach und wenn
zum beispiel eine alte wahl- tätig wird
oder zum beispiel die mährische so wenn
mir besteht also dann schauen wir zurück
und die der wald hätte genau das gleiche
zeit
es wird oft viel lieber ganz leger
typisch sind
warum sie einst mit laune mit einer
spieler
mehr diskutiert lieber das risiko und
den schritt machen
fremont dennis leben schon länger nicht
mehr im sankt gallischen altstätten aber
nun kennt sie immer noch heute gelten
sie als cool und ihren sieg erst recht
mit plus/minus alfred und später von
bord fahren
anfangs leckere gegen die andere darf
man doch gar nicht wissen was alle
machen
zürich mitten in der partyszene
hollywood hottie einige finnischen klub
so forsche doch dominiert so gut
versteckt dass man muss frau prof
mit minirock gestorben
da muss er wollte dass sie ordentlich
bild ja ich meine logistik tochter hat
jetzt wird sie mit minirock schnitt
sogar man dann würde sie niedriger oder
wella begrabscht frauen als freiwild
weil sie sich so an 10 und weil sie so
sind wie es ihnen gefällt begrapscht und
bedrängt werden
das ist für viele junge frauen heute
fast normal
dann können wir das hat jedes programm
aber das von der negativ- behandelt und
dass man nicht einfach ignoriere dort
will so bald nicht mehr macht den habe
ich das gefühl dass man verständnis gibt
aber keine grenzen
und es ist natürlich öffnen war drin
kommen wir so viel kulturen zusammen und
so fiel auch altersmäßig sehr günstiges
viel jünger und mit ihnen dann geht es
ins ski
es gibt männer die sind sagt das ist
kein witz und es gibt männer die ski
die neuesten zahlen belegen sexuelle
belästigung trifft mehr als die hälfte
der jungen frauen
ok
remo schmid ist in zürich aufgewachsen
und kennt die partyszene
er hat in clubs gearbeitet konzerte
veranstaltet er hat oft beobachtet wie
frauen behandelt werden
das problem sagt er seien der alkohol
die drogen und die männer
[Musik]
dann kann der frau dass wir so schnell
dass man sich schnell schnell
[Applaus]
das spiel läuft auf andere
[Musik]
die gewinne gingen frau zu 50 die
auslagen angesprochen dass man als frau
anstatt gesetzt hat sich auf dem bock
gemacht und eine chance nicht so brutal
dass er so macht
remo schmid hat letztes jahr den prix
courage gewonnen weil er mutig
eingeschritten ist als er gesehen hat
wie eine frau geschlagen und sexuell
bedrängt wurde
kann auch viele frauen sich nicht mehr
wohl fühlen auf der straße die fülle
sicherheitslauf erspart dennoch man muss
immer angeschaltet werden
es ist so es muss mit dem als frauchen
vorschlagen wie er sagt
ausnahme von europa geht wird das auch
einfach nichts ganzes kamera weg danke
das ist neu dass auch frauen auf der
straße verprügelt werden einfach so und
mit der gleichen härte
[Musik]
genau das ist der 27 jährigen anna
passiert im moment die hatte ich hab
dank von lippis falsches gesagt bin ich
voll saugen sie alle zur sache nicht
seither ist sie nie mehr am tatort
gewesen
wir gehen mit ihr dorthin zurück an die
hauptstraße in dübendorf wo es passiert
ist
es ist nacht es waren autos vorbei das
quartier ist dicht bewohnte glück dass
auch remo schmid hier wohnt er hörte
ihre schreie und beschließt
nachzuschauen was da los ist der händler
und so sehen wir so wieder da mit der
behinderung bekommen
die arena der täter betrunken und unter
drogen schlägt brutal zu gespürt dass er
hinter mir her und dann haben im notfall
abgetötet und noch eine sache wo ich bin
dann bin ich darüber ganz bank klasse
und da hat er mich dann
er spuckte ja dass das einmal hat mir
geholfen oder einmal von den kopf
geschlagen
einfach nur noch nicht geschlagen remo
schmid allzu hilfe und verhindert dass
andere nicht auch noch sexuell
missbraucht wird und die hätten reagiert
anfangs so kollegiale so verwackelt oder
erlaubnis friedlich freundin und wo ich
dann noch rosig sehen dass eine burg
gehabt dass ich arbeit finden für mich
dass ich jetzt ein star blieb und die
situation des menschens kleider oder
auch mal nur dass sie in sicherheit
nachdem er das gemacht hat das ist eine
bedrohung habe mir da droht auf eine
große und ist dann nach der auslosung
die erinnerung bild auf
so viel schnee gesteckt bin die
vergangene woche auch alles weg war
rhede - wie auch elektriker gestanden
die griffe hat ich denke man nicht so
viel glück neutrale hätte sich mal
lieber schnell auf eine reagieren
schnell helfen aber es ist schade dass
bald wieder dass das manische sich die
gäste trotzdem hat das ist zu schaffen
und das hat sich das passiert ist mir
nach vorne klappt hilft überhand dass
das in zukunft vielleicht das b2b ist
dass das mini mannschaft und hoffe von
kampflos den 30 jährigen täter sieht an
der vor gericht wieder
er wird zu einer bedingten
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt und muss eine
ambulante therapie machen eigentlich
wonach sie habe ganz normal ganz normal
in akko wieder so ein tipp wo man
einfach mit mir sein also bis macht groß
groß
ja
anna belastet der übergriff bis heute
immer noch sucht sie nach einer
erklärung der stadt vor der wahl also
ich einfach immer reifer abgestellt oder
gar keine antworten ja nein zu dem spot
warum er das gemacht hat
ich habe zerschlagen niemand schuld bei
mir gesucht und nachhaltigkeit ist bei
mir ist kein schuld dann aber nicht
hinwerfen warum eine antwort hat sie nie
bekommen
[Musik]
remo schmid hat geholfen hätten andere
das auch gemacht oder wäre die angst
dabei größere sich selber in gefahr zu
bringen ist leider sehr häufig dass
mancher noch eines hauptrunde können
und der mensch werkzeug mit
niederschwellig damit sie es aber nötig
die maschinerie nicht das
negativerlebnis sondern positiv solange
sand das ist immer mal geträumt
die zürcher stadtpolizei wirbt für mehr
zivilcourage mit einer mobilen
beratungsstelle
hier werden mögliche alltagssituationen
nachgestellt zb im tram jemand wird
getrennt wie reagieren
interaktiv kann man auf die situation
einwirken und schauen wie man sich
richtig welt
ist das auch mit zu den ohren muss ich
mit gott so situation wo ich alltägliche
szene in zügen daran dass man die
alleine oder im sport demonstriert der
gruppe von marine und mich dann unwohl
fühlt und nicht weiß wie reagiert und
und ich finde dass das klima dort unter
jungen leuten bewusst machte deutlich
dass es ist sogar sehr überrascht dass
man dem zweiter mit dieser anderen
richtig handeln heißt hinschauen helfen
aber zum eigenen schutz zuerst andere
mobilisieren und die polizei
notrufnummer 117 zivilcourage kann man
lernen und gewalt verhindern
fängt mit einer aufmerksam gesellschaft
an
in basel ist es inzwischen drei uhr in
der früh und die jugendpolizei ist voll
im einsatz was sich lenas aufgebot an
polizei jetzt so viele schätze der
wahnsinns reisegruppe aus kontrollieren
und wieder geht es um ihre macht und
frauen
der eigene typische mit in dort auch ein
anderer machen und so und ios geräte
oder so die polizei setzt klare grenzen
ungewohnt für viele der jugendlichen
dank großer teile sicher prävention
präventiv repressives braucht beides
muster kontakt mit ihm suchen man muss
präsenz zeigen und muss sie auf suchen
wir müssen zeigen dass man sich auch
ganz klar grant zu setzen
das ist jetzt so dazu gehört dass der
blickwinkel sich verantwortet von der
jugendlichen
das match wird oder wie man es vorher
schon den pokal haben dass man irgendwie
kraftausdrücken style das ist ganz
normal zu dax unter der jugendlichen
leider daher zulegen wie der blickwinkel
schon acht ländern
auch ihm ist um diese zeit noch
unterwegs
seit ein paar jahren lebt er in basel
und schaut kritisch auf das was sich
tagtäglich auf der straße abspielt sei
heute dasselbe wie damals sagt er nur
härter
dem viertel darum ist es gut findet ist
also gelder verbuchen
wir machen schon fast blind verkostet
sie den nachweis dass gelöst neu ist die
schlägereien werden gefilmt und ins netz
gestellt als ob die bilder trophäen
werden am meisten nationalitäten meister
zwischen geld miguel der meister
zwischen der rechte kreise also sich so
alles wird irgendwie messe wahrheit
mikrowellen und ländern ja wenn du nicht
weniger heiß schlotter tür oder wendt
mehrheit meint auch von anderen beruf
traum glas ist so ja
wer eine schlägerei sucht der findet sie
ibm führt uns wieder auf den
theaterplatz
die polizei ist nicht mehr vor ort und
unsere kamera unauffällig es geht nicht
lange und schon sind wir live dabei
[Applaus]
hinter mir
[Musik]
die
sie haben
[Musik]
probst
auf dem heuberg sich eigentlich schon
news wir haben ja einige bilder ist
boxen stress und floh er auf seine klage
vor die werkzeuge der wende mit dem
herstellungsdatum wenn du willst
ich glaube walterswil intensive
verknallt aber anders heute gewalt enorm
intensiv begriff der schnelle zugestimmt
verabredet sich schneller also mehr
leute da wir jetzt vor ihm an der wand
knöpfe sind ein remake büro wurde
kollege problem kennt seine kollegen
arbeitet sich ein schönes stück pro sind
kollegen es ist solche brutalen angriff
schneller zu gegenstand und es klappte
schneller auskühlen
der platanenhof team war 15 jahre alt
als er hierher kam
er musste drei jahre bleiben
[Musik]
der plantanenhof galt lange schweizweit
als eines der härtesten jugendheimen ein
heim für solche wie er in einer jetzt
[Musik]
denkt dass man überhaupt noch mal
telefonieren wenn ihr die auswahl ist
also immerhin treibt klar wo ganz lieber
sie sind wirklich bescheid hätte hatten
haben wir beziehung nach ja genau aber
dort sind word doc florida sind sascha
krüger und ich habe das nicht denkt und
jetzt aber so da alles ändere
mit dir habe ich am meisten gestritten
am meisten sein verweigerung sitz das
hätte zwei browser ist man dort war auch
der 40 unternehmen wie blöd doch das
gehörte damals und auch heute noch zum
konzept sehr renitent ist und sich nicht
an regeln hält wird in einer einzelzelle
gesperrt war oft hier ja fast nicht mehr
ganz so junge käuferschaft damit umgehe
in der nacht hat jetzt 130 also noch 800
als wirtschaftsnah 800 leid und noch
irgendwie so lang dass wieder heftig
wird und irgendwann noch 40 stunden
wünsche ich der geht nun umgesetzt es
ist also das
mit mächtig viel zu holen es ist
schwierig
also ist es schwierig die meinen die
eine kreisbewegung und nun ist und eine
dickere im kreistag die energiedichte
fühlte fühlte 40 und dann präsentieren
heißt zum salon tantal stören also dann
konnten flüchten viele kleider nach
hause arbeitet sie verhindert sie dem
buch das sie überhaupt nicht so qualität
gewonnen hat glaubt erhält müsse das
ganze libysche vor sie also die wut in
mir die idee ist vor gewisse ereignisse
haltungen gehindert oder in der jugend
passieren er sei nur bis renault
passiert dass sie bald weg oder
abschwöre aber dass sie nie gibt es ist
ganz langen es anders laufen in
einzelhaft hat er seine ersten rap texte
geschrieben und ein ventil für seine
aggressionen gefunden
wenn sie nach europa herunter fusion ja
also der der einem so müsste seine
geschichte auf rollen geschichte von der
familie von dem ganzen umfeld ganze
situation mutter und überforderung also
ich finde einfach da da sind sicher die
sag mal so der staat von dem ganzen
gewesen ich finde sogar schon ein
bisschen der selbst überlassen oder ja
gewisse situationen im leben zu ja ja
wohl immer gut aufgewachsen ohne vater
oder mit einem anderen fall also immer
stiefvater und so also und sozialen
problemen die idee die feste beziehungen
haben ihm gefällt und mutter war da
natürlich alle ein oder die ursache für
viele junge tradition also wenn ich
jetzt einige ich will jetzt nicht
einfach die mütter verurteilung sagen
alle alleinstehenden mutter sind
schaffen es nicht oder so also aber
tatsächlich sind die zerrüttete familien
also das ist schon sehr schlimm für die
jugendlichen verlust vom vater also
einfach keine anwesen also das ganze
umfeld umso mehr die soziale kontrolle
da ist umso mehr lüth sie füllen sie
behütet dass es wieder nicht und wenn da
wenn er nichts zerstört die sozusagen
dann dann fühlt man sich da allein
gelassen
heiring hat hier auch seine ausbildung
nachgeholt
[Musik]
wir sind der frau jetzt ja wieder mal
schneller als altmodisch die
gewerkschaftsbosse jedoch immer noch auf
einiges freuen erklärt aber nicht
angestellt werde er die ganzen sind wir
ja
[Musik]
rim hat hier bekommen was er dringend
brauchte strukturen und letztlich auch
menschen die an ihn geglaubt haben
[Musik]
wollte skrupel davor die macht niemand
verletzt und ich mache das auch per web
mache ja ein ventil gefunden dass sie an
der mine kann erstaunt ist ultra
schreien und da ist eigentlich los sein
und dann bin ich auch recht behaupten
kann ich mir auch auf das große
provozieren und die haben druckvoller
und dann ist man da eigentlich auge ja
das macht man denn eigentlich bin ich
aber schaue ventil braucht weil die
energie ist nach wie vor da und ich
versuche positive energie umzuwandeln
und tomo die nummer zwei also ich habe
da haste wie hat zwar die energie und
die rebellion aber das ist immer so böse
david der 22 jährige junge mann der
einen passanten brutal mit dem messer
angegriffen und ausgeraubt hat sitzt
noch bis november 2023 im gefängnis
im erwachsenen vollzug ist der hart auf
dem boden der realität gelandet
das hat mir ein kapitel über rom platt
weil ich sehr mag
man ist irgendwie gar nicht so schlimm
borken / mitte zieht und ich bin da auch
hin und her anfang nicht die situation
anpassen
das soll jetzt behaupte frischen
sommerhalbjahr jetzt das markengesetz
ist nachdenken darüber was eigentlich in
die tat keine gemacht dann eine ganz
süße aber was für ein ausmass zitate
okay für alle beteiligten bewusst eine
welle das ist mir bewusst ist dass
absichtlich versenkt märkte zu erwachsen
und ja quasi den betrieb gegangen weil
ich dann ja man kann wohl nicht so
vorbereitet kann natürlich leichter dann
ist man selber kann man muss meist
bringt
david arbeitet im gefängnis in der
metallverarbeitung
wenn er sich gut verhält dann kann er
vielleicht die gefängniszeit nutzen und
eine ausbildung machen
ohne aus dem täter ein opfer machen zu
wollen
die frage bleibt dennoch was muss in
einer biografie alles schieflaufen dass
so eine entwicklung möglich ist
na ja hoffen
und ja viel verschenkt das ist das am
meisten schmerzt
und das opfer viele bleiben nach so
einem übergriff traumatisiert josef
warten weil er sagt er habe die tat
verarbeitet ist es eine genugtuung für
ihn zu wissen dass der täter bestraft
wurde
das strafmaß ist wirklich so ich bin
froh ist gefasst worden
und er hat vor ort hat dort auch um sich
darüber aber jetzt da die krawallige
pakistan ist social media vz ganze
familie
abschließend ist definitiv dass man so
ein tag ohne mittel zum krieg haben nach
der gerichtsverhandlung zu bewusst so
erleichtert es fertig ganz und ihr steht
am anfang seiner karriere
[Musik]
kostet ja es hat doch jeder den bisher
postierte sword jedes pferd das quartett
und den analysiert sind wenig wasser
kommt heiß und kräftig heraus und dass
die kanadier haben und die stürmer tor
ist die die kämpfe pro woche finden
dieser preis bedeutet das heute kommt
die bürgerforen die opfer die theorie
vom blockbuster aus bremervörde tage
panik und auch die zähne putzen
[Musik]